[Musique]
après une multitude de violences et de
massacres voilà six ans quelques 700 000
rohinga se sont réfugiés au Bangladesh
mais comme vient de nous le démontrer ce
documentaire réalisé par gwen lawen le
green il s'agit là en réalité de
l'achèvement d'une politique de
discrimination des gens ancienne et
minutieusement mise en place par le
régime birman à l'époque l'ONU dénonça
un nettoyage ethnique et plus tard un
génocide ou en étant aujourd'hui nous
allons en débattre maintenant sur ce
plateau de débat doc avec nos invités en
commençant par vous Sophie Brondel
bienvenue vous êtes la coordinatrice du
site info Birmanie qui réalise un
travail d'information et de plaidoyer
sur la situation des droits humains dans
ce pays Olivier Guyard est également
avec nous bienvenue vous êtes chercheur
spécialiste de l'Asie aux cerias le
Centre d'études de recherche sur l'Inde
l'Asie du Sud et sa diaspora de
l'Université du Québec c'est à Montréal
votre dernier livre se situe
l'inquiétante République islamique du
Pakistan il a été publié chez
L'Harmattan et puis enfin Antoine
Madelin est également avec nous
bienvenue à vous vous êtes le directeur
du plaidoyer de la Fédération
internationale pour les droits humains
la fi DH on va commencer par une carte
si vous voulez bien pour resituer bien
sûr la Birmanie la Birmanie qui est une
ancienne colonie de l'Empire britannique
qui a qui son indépendance en 1900 48 à
l'inconnu essentiellement des dictatures
militaires avec une parenthèse
démocratique en 2016 nous allons y
revenir tout à l'heure et puis ce pays a
subi un nouveau coup d'État c'était en
février 2021 c'est à nouveau une jante
militaire qui dirige ce pays aujourd'hui
la capitale est ni paille d'armes le
pays compte 56,5 millions d'habitants
environ en rouge sur cette carte figure
l'état de rakin en réalité l'ex-état de
larakan cité dans le film que nous
venons de voir
des idées et une majorité de rohing Gas
qui ont donc trouvé refuge en 2017
notamment du côté du Bangladesh et dans
ces camps de réfugiés situés notamment à
coxbazar que vous voyez apparaître en
bleu sur cette carte Sophie Brondel
après ce film la question que nous
allons nous poser c'est où en est-on
aujourd'hui concernant ce nettoyage
ethnique ce génocide selon l'ONU
concernant les rowing-gas chez nos
confrères belges suisses pardon de RTS
vous avez déclaré c'était en août
dernier même si une grande majorité
d'héroïne gaz aspire à rentrer chez eux
avec la jante au pouvoir à savoir les
militaires qui sont les mêmes qui les
ont massacrés il n'y a pas de
perspective de retour
j'imagine que vous n'avez pas changé
d'avis depuis cette déclaration non
malheureusement cette déclaration elle
est toujours d'actualité en Birmanie il
faut savoir que les 120 000 près de 120
000 déplacés qu'on voit dans le
documentaire qui se trouve dans des
camps que des officiels virement
qualifient eux-mêmes de camp de
concentration des camps de déplacer les
conditions pour ces déplacer sont
toujours les mêmes ils n'ont aucun droit
aucune liberté de mouvement les médias
locaux se font régulièrement les codes
de rohinga qui cherche à fuir ces
situations qui se retrouvent condamnées
à des peines lourdes d'emprisonnement en
Birmanie et donc pour l'héroïne a en
Birmanie il y a toujours ce système
institutionnalisé d'apartheid c'est les
termes employés par Amnesty
International pour qualifier la
situation des rohinga en Birmanie ce
système est toujours en place donc le
retour en Birmanie est absolument
impossible sous la jante actuelle il
faut ajouter que la situation dans les
camps au Bangladesh se dégrade et c'est
ça aussi qui vient compliquer la
situation c'est à dire que les capacités
d'accueil du Bangladesh sont limitées ça
fait cinq ans que procédure et dans les
camps du Bangladesh tous les éléments
tous les facteurs se détériorent il y a
moins d'aide internationales donc les
besoins vitaux d'héroïdiens ne sont pas
satisfaits l'insécurité grandit et les
autorités Bangladesh prennent de plus en
plus de mesures restrictives qui
viennent compliquées la situation il a
les conditions de survie dans les camps
surpeuplés du Bangladesh donc les
réfugiés rowinga en fait face à cette
situation bien sûr aspire à rentrer en
Birmanie mais ils ne peuvent il ne le
peuvent pas et ils en viennent parfois à
fuir les camps du Bangladesh pour
prendre la mer pour aller en Malaisie
etc dans d'autres pays on voit une
augmentation drastique des bots people
rohinga sur l'année 2022 beaucoup de
réfugiés ont une gars qui cherchent à
fuir les camps du Bangladesh qui ne
peuvent pas rentrer en Birmanie
actuellement on avait cru comprendre et
on a compris dans ce documentaire qui a
eu un accord entre le Bangladesh et la
Birmanie pour organiser ce retour des
rowing-gas
à terme en Birmanie il y a peu de cas
que ça se produise avec l'agent de
pouvoir aujourd'hui dans le pays alors
des avants donc le coup d'État de
février 2021 la possibilité d'un
rapatriement massif et volontaire de
rungia vers leur patrie d'origine donc
vers la reine était proche de zéro
quasiment deux ans plus tard on n'a pas
beaucoup avancé davantage non pas tant
que il n'y ait pas le souhait d'une
petite fraction de la population ringa
déplacé de revenir sur dans le lieu de
d'origine mais ils savent très bien
qu'ils ne sont pas les bienvenus très
honnêtement la population locale celle
qui reste donc on a eu c'était très bien
mis en valeur dans votre documentaire il
y a quelques quelques instants n'est pas
du tout prête à refaire de la place donc
dans un paysage qui a drastiquement
changé de toute manière de ces six
dernières années j'étais sur place il y
a un peu après le qui était tourné ce
documentaire ça ça discutablement
énormément changé et pour être franc la
communauté internationale relativement
indifférente au sort donc des runes ne
s'est pas davantage particulièrement
autant mobiliser qu'elle l'aurait pu ce
qui vaut donc la communauté
internationale de la part de cette
minorité un sentiment de de négligence
ou d'abandon qui confine un petit peu à
la réalité du terrain donc
malheureusement cette en 2023 les choses
n'ont certainement pas évolué dans le
bon sens pour cette minorité alors
concernant justement ce qui a été la
réaction de cette communauté
internationale qu'est-ce qu'on peut en
dire aujourd'hui 6 ans après
se nettoyage ethnique auquel on a
assisté a-t-elle réagi est-elle encore
en capacité de le faire pour un retour
éventuel de séroine case que sur ce
plateau on juge quasiment impossible si
j'ai bien compris vos propos
je crois que face à un massacre aussi
important que ce qu'on a pu voir la
chose la plus importante qui est aussi
demandé par les victimes c'est la
justice et face à cette demande qu'a
fait la communauté internationale à ce
stade dans un premier temps les Nations
unies sous l'égide du coût de d'État mis
en place des commissions d'enquête pour
essayer de documenter les crimes qui ont
été commis pour aussi déterminer les
responsables dans un deuxième temps et
c'était accéléré avec le coup d'État il
va les responsable ils sont aujourd'hui
au pouvoir c'est bien évidemment donc
les Nations Unies ont décrété que voilà
les personnes dont on estime qu'ils sont
responsables de ces crimes mais bon il
n'y a pas de mandat d'arrêt contre pour
autant dans un deuxième temps il y a et
le régime actuel n'est pas reconnu par
la communauté internationale
officiellement alors une simplifie pas
les choses il y a tout un débat en effet
depuis que la jungle a pris le pouvoir
par la force pour savoir qui est
l'autorité légitime à qui nous devons
parler mais dans la majorité des
situations aujourd'hui la junte qui a
pris le pouvoir par la force reste le
premier interlocuteur privilégié de la
communauté internationale
l'opposition aujourd'hui qui est
constitué un gouvernement civil essaie
d'avoir cette reconnaissance
internationale mais peine à avoir une
reconnaissance à ce propos mais donc
pour revenir sur cette question de
justice internationale
quelque part ont été faits le Bangladesh
a pu saisir la Cour pénale
internationale pour que le procureur
puisse mener une enquête sur le
déplacement forcé il y a également eu
des enquêtes qui ont été menées dans
différentes juridictions de Parlement
grâce à ce qu'on appelle la compétence
universelle c'est une compétence qui
permet à des juges d'intervenir en
Allemagne en Argentine en Turquie alors
que les crimes n'ont pas été commis sur
leur propre territoire mais dès lors
qu'il y a des victimes présents sur leur
terrain
et donc nous voyons nous un certain
nombre d'initiatives pour essayer de
mener des enquêtes et pour pouvoir à
terme poursuivre les responsables de ces
violations
oui je voulais peut-être rebondir sur la
question du rapatriement parce qu'en ce
moment la jinte affiche une volonté
soi-disant de rapatrier des réfugiés
rowingiens et c'est clairement
2018 le discours du rapatriement et dans
le et celui des autorités officielles
sans que rien ne change sur le terrain
et là on voit que la jungle qui est mise
en difficulté quand même parce qu'elle
est sous sanction internationale et elle
est isolée et finalement elle est allée
avec qui avec la Russie avec la Chine ça
devient un état paria donc sous pression
internationale aussi elle affiche une
volonté de rapatriement mais qui
manifestement ne peut avoir lieu c'est
intéressant c'est important de mettre en
avant l'instrumentalisation de cette
question rowing-ga par par la gente et
sur le volet justice internationale il
faut peut-être aussi enfin évoquer la
requête de la Gambie devant la Cour
internationale de justice qui met alors
cette requête met en cause la
responsabilité de l'État Birmant pour
violation de la Convention sur le
génocide et il faut souligner que il y a
des états comme le Canada les Pays-Bas
et plus récemment en 2022 l'Allemagne et
le Royaume-Uni qui ont officiellement
rejoint cette requête gambienne nous
nous demandons la fideh info Birmanie
est beaucoup d'autres organisations de
la société civile que la France
elle-même appuie formellement cette
requête et je pense qu'elle le doit au
ringa tu n'es pas le cas aujourd'hui qui
n'est pas le cas à l'heure actuelle et
je pense que c'est très important que
notre pays sonore a rejoint de cette
requête il en va de notre mobilisation
par rapport à ces enjeux de justice
internationale puisque l'héroïda
attendent que justice leur soit rendue
le temps qui passe c'est autant de déni
de justice et c'est vrai que ça ne peut
pas durer on doit vraiment tout mettre
en oeuvre pour montrer qu'on appuie les
initiatives de justice internationale
qui existent alors il y en a tué qui
était au centre de cette affaire c'est
Hanson Suki une sunsuki c'était la
Madone de la démocratie the lady c'était
le surnom qu'on lui avait donné au sein
de la communauté internationale
justement prix Nobel de la paix en
1991 elle a aussi reçu la Légion
d'honneur du côté français est arrivé au
pouvoir au poste on va dire de Premier
ministre pour faire une similitude avec
la France c'est pas tout à fait son
titre mais elle avait donc le pouvoir du
côté birman avec cette transition
démocratique auquel on a assisté en 2016
est-ce qu'elle est responsable tout ou
en partie de ce nettoyage ethnique
auquel on a assisté avec cette
population héroïne gaz alors responsable
probablement non directement non est-ce
qu'elle est l'instigatrice primaire de
cette tragédie humaine sans nom ces
dernières années probablement pas après
il est vrai on attendait beaucoup de la
dame une fois arrivé au pouvoir donc
c'était oublier également donc peut-être
pour venir un petit peu au secours de
cette dame qui est en Bastille depuis
maintenant un peu plus de deux ans sans
avoir recouvrir la liberté elle a 33 ans
de prison pour l'instant de de peine qui
sont condamnés à 33 ans de prison vous
venez de le dire c'est une prisonnière
politique aujourd'hui indiscutablement
son état de santé n'est pas
extraordinaire par ailleurs et bon on a
malheureusement un petit peu à lui avoir
elle est tombée peut-être par son manque
d'action son manque d'engagement et son
manque de résistance face à la face au
militaires de son piédesten elle ne
serait plus la bienvenue donc une
capitale de démocratie occidentale
aujourd'hui parce qu'on lui reproche de
ne pas avoir un fait montre de
suffisamment de crampes pour s'opposer
au militaires c'est peut-être un petit
peu oublié que toute conserve d'État
qu'elle était donc tout officieuse des
facto chef de fe de l'État birman à
l'époque elle n'avait pas tout le
instruments du pouvoir et s'opposer donc
dans la Birmanie contemporaine comme
dans celle des années 90 ou des années
70 à la volonté des généraux même en
profitant d'un soutien populaire fort
c'est ce risquer à entre guillemets à
avoir donc une recevoir sur la
quasi-totalité des dossiers qu'elle
gérait elle leur est certainement dû ça
c'est une certitude faire davantage on
en attendait davantage d'aller dans la
pas fait on lui en sait beaucoup gris et
elle ne sait peut-être pas très bien
défendue jusqu'à lors donc de cette elle
aurait pu faire davantage cette
certitude elle aurait probablement aimé
en faire un peu plus on a pu le vérifier
est-ce que ça aurait suffi à emporter la
la décision près des biens
internationale je ne suis mal
heureusement j'en suis pas certain vous
évoquez les nécessaires interlocuteurs
évidemment avec ce qui s'est passé sur
place pour faire respecter les droits
humains sur place on Suki aurait pu être
c'est interlocutrice
au moment où elle a été au pouvoir
est-ce qu'elle a seulement été où est-ce
qu'elle a fermé les yeux faute de
pouvoir justement de réels pouvoirs au
sein de ce gouvernement birman les
organisations rowing-ga les
organisations de défense des droits
humains on saisit on s'assuki qui a
balayé le revers de la main la situation
et on le voit d'ailleurs dans le
documentaire puisque la rapporteur
spécial des Nations Unies c'est une amie
connaissait qui a là aussi interpellé
directement et cette dernière a aussi
voilà
et pour aller un petit peu plus loin
aussi puisqu'on parlait de
la requête devant la Cour internationale
de Justice venu aussi représenter le
gouvernement birman devant cette Cour de
justice elle est venue en personne
d'ailleurs pour justifier quelque part
les politiques ou en tout cas essayer de
d'assumer la défense du des politiques
qui étaient mises en place c'est une
grande désillusion de qui dans ce
dossier en effet par rapport à ce que
montre le documentaire il y a des prises
de position donc son sushi qui ne relève
pas juste de savoir dans quel état
d'esprit elle était quand elle n'a pas
pris position pour l'héroïne bien
puisqu'on sait très bien que le contexte
en Birmanie était très complexe
effectivement les militaires menaient le
jeu donc ça marche de manœuvre était
peut-être réduite mais le documentaire
montre bien qu'il y a des prises de
position il ne faut pas nommer l'héroïda
ou cette question et aborder d'un point
de vue occidental alors qu'il était
question de violation des droits de
l'homme et de crimes donc ça c'est pas
une version
occidentale de la situation d'héroïna il
faut quand même souligner aussi qu'il y
a une plainte qui a été déposée au nom
de la compétence universelle en
Argentine par l'ONG basée à Londres qui
vise en fonction donc je pense que les
responsabilités au niveau de des
responsables à la fois militaires et de
des personnes qui dirigent le
gouvernement LND à l'époque relève d'un
débat judiciaire et que il faut
peut-être qu'on arrête aussi parce que
c'est quelque chose qui nous revient
souvent de dire que enfin de rentrer
dans l'état d'esprit ou dans les raisons
profondes pour lesquelles onction aurait
ou n'aurait pas sous un n'aurait pas du
coup soutenu l'héroïne bien ça on n'en
sait rien mais je pense que le débat se
situe quand même sur un niveau
judiciaire et parce qu'on aborde bien
sûr les la question des massacres
qualifications pénales des massacres
menés par les militaires mais il y a
aussi qualification pénale de tout ce
système d'appartaï d'institutionnel
quand on déni aux personnes d'exister à
travers toute une série de lois et qui
relevés de la compétence du gouvernement
LND la responsabilité juridique de ce
gouvernement enfin
la démocratie peut être posée et je
pense qu'il faut le renvoyer un débat
judiciaire qui sera sur un temps long
alors tout ça s'inscrit aujourd'hui en
2023 dans un contexte très particulier
en Birmanie ces derniers jours on a
assisté à un massacre suite à un
bombardement du régime actuel sur des
opposants au régime ces opposants sont
le PDF les forces de défense du peuple
qui s'oppose donc à la junte militaire
aujourd'hui en place cette jante
militaire a choisi visiblement la
répression en ce début du mois d'avril
avec déjà plusieurs dizaines de victimes
de morts dont des enfants des femmes
bombardées par le régime
birman
on est au bord d'une guerre civile en
Birmanie ça ne doit pas faciliter les
choses pour tenter de régler un tant
soit peu le problème qui nous préoccupe
le problème d'héroïne à s'imagine c'est
une certitude je pense même qu'on est
entré dans la guerre civile il y a
probablement au moins une bonne douzaine
de mois donc il y a un an vous évoquez
un instant les PDF les peoples defense
forces sortent de milice pour démocratie
locale qui sont en soutien des forces
démocratique des partisans de la
de la Ligue nationale de la démocratie
qui sont contre la jungle si dans une
bonne acception du terme c'est une
mission 4 se sont multipliées à une
vitesse incroyable elle se coordonne
désormais depuis à peu près 6 mois à 12
mois elle profite de formation et de
d'un échange d'expertise avec ce que
l'on appelle les groupes ethniques armés
donc ce sont ceux les professionnels de
la résistance armée contre les
majoritaire bavard donc depuis parfois
existant depuis plusieurs dizaines
d'années tout ce petit monde là oppose
aujourd'hui une résistance sur à peu
près les deux tiers du pays à l'armée
qui reconnaît qu'elle n'a pas la main
mise sur le sur la totalité du
territoire loin de là et le recours de
l'armée entre guillemets pour faire face
à la fois à ses front qu'elle n'avait
pas vu venir
plus la résistance de la société civile
de la population locale des populations
ethniques consiste à élever l'intensité
du recours moyen dont elle dispose donc
c'est ce sont des des armes comme
l'évocat Sophie tout à l'heure acheter
auprès des deux seuls soutiens
diplomatiques que sont la Chine est la
Russie tout dernièrement elle emploie un
usage disproportionné de la force pour
essayer de reprendre la main ou en tous
les cas envoyer un message d'extrême
fermeté malgré les coups de canifs
qu'elle subit donc effectivement nous
sommes probablement il n'est pas certain
que ce que c'est ce qui s'est passé ces
derniers jours donc malheureusement
c'est bien une population civile qui
célébrait l'arrivée pratiquement de la
fête de l'eau donc un moment bouddhique
et bouddhiste est bien extrêmement
important dans le pays il est pas
interdit de penser que l'armée va
probablement recourir davantage dans le
futur à ce déploiement de force
intolérable qui s'agit évidemment du
sujet ici aujourd'hui et dans spartooli
bien aussi l'imaginable et c'est dans ce
contexte qu'il s'agit de faire respecter
un tant soit peu les droits humains
élémentaires alors tu imagines cette
facilite pas les choses
on est dans une situation où les
bombardements en Birmanie les six
derniers mois sont à tout le moins 50%
plus importants que ce que l'on a pu
documenter en Ukraine pour faire un
comparaison avec une autre crise donc on
voit dont on parle davantage dans dans
l'actualité
la communauté internationale n'a pas
réagi comme elle devrait le faire
malheureusement le Conseil de sécurité a
été saisi de cette situation
en décembre dernier et une résolution a
été adoptée qui demande aux autoris des
birmanes de suspendre
ses attaques et de libérer les
prisonniers d'opinion et sans qu'il y
ait une quelconque force en tout cas
décision qui soit prise en conséquence
par le concept de sécurité nous
demandons aujourd'hui qu'il y ait un
embargo sur les ventes d'armes pour que
cette ce cette prolifération en tout cas
de de la réponse armée puisse cesser
est-ce que ce régime peut être renversé
et ce que ça peut influer sur le sort
réservé demain si éventuellement
rowing-gas est-ce que je peux compléter
juste sur ce point
donc du coup sur la question des rohinga
des enjeux de justice et de la situation
de guerre civile c'est avec la jante
mène vraiment une guerre contre le
peuple dans son ensemble et contre la
majorité Bach qui est nouveau est-ce
qu'on peut voir par rapport à la cause
rowinga c'est que depuis le coup d'État
on a quand même une prise de conscience
d'une partie de la population bammar du
sort réservé au runga aux minorités et
donc de d'une perception nouvelle de la
du sort d'héroïga c'est important ce que
vous dites là parce qu'il faisait assez
peu de cas des héroïnes gazon Suki fait
partie de cette ethnie et ça fait partie
des points d'interrogation de savoir
dans quelle mesure la société birmane
peut changer par rapport au fait que
tout le monde est confronté au crime de
l'armée il y a encore beaucoup de
divisions mais il y a des organisations
présentes de la société civile qui
soutiennent les demandes de justice des
rohinga et je pense que du coup le
peuple bienment se fédère sur les
demande de justice internationale ça
c'est important de le souligner et pour
répondre à ma question parce que
malheureusement on approche de la fin de
cette émission et ce qu'un changement de
régime changerait la donne concernant le
rapatriement éventuel des rowing-gas par
rapport à par rapport à cette question
ce qu'on peut souligner c'est que le
gouvernement d'unité nationale donc il y
ait le gouvernement en résistance a pris
un certain nombre de adopter un certain
nombre de déclarations par le biais de
son ministre des Droits Humains
englomine qui a déclaré que le
gouvernement d'unité nationale s'engager
à annuler la loi de la citoyenneté 1982
qui rend l'héroïne apatrides et qui sont
et qui s'est engagé à le reconnaître la
citoyenneté alors bien sûr ce sont des
déclarations de papier tant que le tank
ce gouvernement là n'est pas n'est pas
au pouvoir donc ça se sont quand même
des premiers éléments en tout cas de
position par rapport à ce gouvernement
en résistance mais il faut savoir que
par rapport à ça du coup les rengates
demandent à ce gouvernement d'aller plus
loin et de nommer un membre rowing-ga en
son sein pour montrer qu'au début de
l'affichage il y a vraiment une volonté
d'inclure l'héroïne à dans la Birmanie
de demain voilà à ce stade c'est vrai
que c'est difficile de savoir ce qu'il
en serait si la jante est démantelée et
si un nouveau gouvernement venait à
avoir le jour je pense que c'est à ce
stade très difficile de savoir si
l'héroïne a verrait leurs droits
reconnus puisqu'il y a beaucoup de
divisions à surmonter et je pense que du
coup le fait de rendre justice au
rohinga aussi c'est absolument essentiel
pour qu'il puisse envisager aussi de
vivre dans la démocratie de la Birmanie
pardon de demain qui on l'espère sera
débarrasser du jeu de la dictature je
vous laisse le mot de la fin le verbe
vous partagez pleinement ce qui vient
d'être dit ou avec quelques nuances dans
une grande mesure oui comme assez
souvent si ce n'est que peut-être un
petit peu tempéré cette optimisme une
majorité de doberman pense qu'il y a
probablement une infinité de priorité à
engager aujourd'hui ou demain en
Birmanie plutôt que de s'occuper
prioritairement du sort de cette
minorité ce qui est absolument
désastreux ce que ce qui ne dure pas
d'une avancée même dans l'hypothèse d'un
retour d'un régime hybride ou
démocratique probablement plus à moyen
terme qu'à court terme donc l'optimisme
doit être tempéré par la réalité birmane
la réalité birmane d'une réalité dure
pour les minorités et notamment pour
cette minorité royale de tout évident ça
sera le mot de la fin vraiment un grand
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à cette émission des Badoc consacrée au
sort des rowing-gas après se nettoyage
ethnique ce génocide pour reprendre les
termes utilisés par les Nations Unies de
2017 et qu'on a revu à travers le film
que nous avons proposé dans cette
émission vos réactions ça sera sur
hashtag débadoc sur Twitter merci aussi
à sel massali qui m'a aidé comme à
l'accoutumée à préparer cette émission
je vous donne tout simplement
rendez-vous pour un prochain débat doc
et ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]